jeff snyder here for collider and i'm
sitting
down with the team behind pleasure which
premieres at the sundance film festival
this weekend
i'm with writer director ninja tyberg
and star sophia cappell thank you guys
for coming
thank you for having me so ninja for the
folks at home who who
you know haven't seen this movie and
haven't seen a trailer tell us you know
what it is
actually about yes it's a film about
a 19 year old swedish girl who goes to
lay with ambition of becoming the next
big porn star
and we the film starts when she arrives
in l.a
and we get to follow her on this journey
uh
into the porn industry world
and discover it um together with her
and why is it that you wanted to make a
movie that looks at the sex industry
from the female perspective
i've been interested in porn as a
subject for
oh yeah it's actually 20 years now i'm
that old
and i've been interested in the subject
for many different reasons
and i started out as uh anti-porn
activists
activist
so that was like my first how the
journey began but then
um yeah i've just been dealing with the
subject for a very long time
and i think it's there's so many thing
like different reasons
uh why this subject fascinates me
and i mean one of the reasons is that it
is taboo and no one wants to talk about
it
and also i am very interested in gender
roles
and media images and how that affects
our identities so when it comes to porn
it's really like
very like traditional gender roles taken
to its most extreme form
um and i think it's also it fascinates
me that this medium
is so i mean they say that
eighty percent of all the traffic on
internet
is porn like people consume like this
an insane amount of porn so of course
it's something that really affects us
and that is a huge part of our culture
but it's in a world like it exists in a
world of shadows no one wants to talk
about it and we don't really
uh acknowledge it like publicly so
that's why i feel like this film really
needs
it needs to exist and we need to like uh
admit that this is something that exists
and also because i am very interested in
uh power from different
angles uh and and the porn traditional
heterosexual porn is very very
like male gaze oriented and that's why
i i felt that it was a perfect example
or like a perfect irena to make
an example of to to like pinpoint
that by uh reversing the gaze
because it becomes very like obvious
i i thought it was you know interesting
seeing the the things that i often see
in in pornography from the reverse angle
from her perspective
uh and so sophia i wanted to ask you um
you know i understand this is your first
film
so and it's very hardcore so what was
the audition process like for you
well the audition process it started out
me with me talking with a friend that i
a ninja have in common
um and he just said that i should try it
out and i think i didn't really
realize how big of a project it was
when i went there because when i went
there there was a lot of other girls
there waiting
um but i had gotten i think like two
scenes
so i had read read a script and
tried to practice it but my first
audition i was super super nervous and i
was
shaking and i told ninja that i was
nervous but it went really well
and then then just told me at the first
audition
that she wanted me back for a call back
which
at the point i didn't realize was super
good um
but then i went back and then i did a
couple more before ninja told me that
the part was mine so you win this role i
mean
what scares you most about it like you
know what what is sort of the biggest
challenge in your eyes that you have to
get your your head around
i wouldn't say that it that there's
anything with the rule that
or like the movie that per se scared me
like there was a lot of things that were
very challenging but i
think that there's a huge difference
because
of course i needed to have a lot of
courage to do this movie because
i'm giving a lot of myself
but i think the hardest part was
that i am so much alike
bella so sometimes i had trouble keeping
them
separate knowing who is sofia and who is
bella i was hard
sometimes but i mean bella is a great
girl
so i don't mind um i know you're
surrounded here by
you know almost the entire cast is sort
of from the the porn industry
uh ninja you know did can you sort of
tell me about coming to l.a earning the
trust of the people in
in this community and did you ever look
at non-porn actors for these roles
yeah um the the end result that it's
only
uh like real people playing the part
that was never
my ambition or i don't think i
dared to like have that
it felt like i knew that i wanted some
people because that's how i've been
working before
to combine professional actors with more
type costed
uh people when when it's something very
specific that you want
someone who has that lived that
experience
uh in order to do it uh justice but um
uh yeah so we addition-wise like i think
it was it was like just a few weeks
before
filming starting like shooting that we
realized like okay actually this is it's
just
all like because no one else none of the
actors like regular actors that we
auditioned
they just didn't get the part uh but it
wasn't a decision
it was just that how it turned out in
the end so something that we realized
like oh jesus it's
actually only like real people in in
playing all the parts
um but um because they did it better
like it was just much more believable
and also i
felt that that was such a difference
between
like when when auditioning them because
i i worked a lot with improv
uh and they could like the people from
the porn world they were able to
improvise uh also in situations where
i wasn't entirely sure like i didn't
know like 100
all the details in the situation but but
i knew that what they are doing is
always going to be
a hundred percent accurate um
so that also kind of way like it was a
relief for me
as a director that it wasn't all my um
responsibility to like present
all the like information and the details
in every single
aspect of everything but uh the way i
earned their trust was it took a long
time the first time i went to la was in
um
2014 so it was like during this
research period were like four years
uh um and um
[Music]
it was just like slowly like step by
step
like meeting one person interviewing
them uh and i had a very open mind and i
told them like i have so many
um like yeah what do you call it father
so if that helped me
yeah prejudice um and um
so and i was honest with that like i
don't know this world uh
and but i i want to learn and i want to
know the
the authentic side of it and
then i i think they felt that i was
honest in my ambition of really
getting to know them and so step by step
like one person
introduced me to the next one and then
after a while it didn't take me that
long to
get access to to shoots to be able to
come and visit
porn sets and then there were just
several people
there that i could just like talk to and
it was easier at first like i didn't go
to like the famous porn stars at the
beginning
and like trying to connect with them but
to like the crew members and people that
normally aren't used to like
people like chasing them and wanting to
hear or interview them
so for them um like just yeah crew
members
uh they like
yeah they weren't used to someone paying
them that much interest
uh so that was a good way to start and
then after a while like
after spending so much time there uh
after
after a while everybody just got used to
me and just saw me as a part of their
community i think
um sophia i wanted to ask about the the
rough sex scene that comes in about
halfway through the film uh
yeah you're talking about about like
blocking that scene out with with your
co-stars and
sort of you know what what the three of
you or for you did to to make you feel
comfortable and safe
yeah um well first of all
we started blocking that scene
i think a couple weeks prior to even
starting
starting to shoot the movie um
with the actor who's bill bailey he's
the blonde guy
and we started like walking out from
which positions that they could move you
easily um while
at the same time it looking really
really rough without it actually hurting
me
um and then we practiced like
being pulled by the hair because there's
a couple of tricks that you do
so it really doesn't hurt you but it
looks horrible or like horrifying
um and then the day we shot that scene
um we did basically the same procedure
we started blocking out
what positions that i could move from
and
um we had like a go through
like what things i could do to um
ease like from getting if i was
strangled or choked i could put my
fingers and that would help a lot or i
would
i really really like um i don't know how
to say like tense my body
so that my head or my face would turn
really really red
and that looks really scary without it
actually being scary
um but most of it was also like talking
um and putting very clear
boundaries of how far i
was willing to go and how far i would
let them go and a lot of
practicing and with between each take
um they would um like kiss me on the
forehead and give me hugs
and tell me nice things um
to also like remind like the
the psychological part of it um to be
reminded that it's
not for real and that they actually care
about me and that these
that all of these guys who are in this
scene are people i really really trust
um because that was something that me
and ninja discussed
a long time before us even starting
us even starting to shoot the movie um
which
um guys that i would trust doing that
scene with
because that was really important to me
so there was a lot of discussion and
talking
and trying and testing
before we did it and i think that ninja
can
vouch for me when i say that us shooting
that scene was one of the
uh times when i was the happiest on set
um i thought it was a lot of fun um and
i had a super
uh super rush of adrenaline all day um
so it was fun even though it looks
horrifying
um yeah i think i know the answer to
this question
um but i mean do you guys did you have
any kind of intimacy coordinator on the
set that like you know
that's the sort of position that they
would have nowadays in
a hollywood movie but did you have
anything anything like that you didn't
have that
uh because that didn't uh i don't think
it existed
at that point where i had never heard of
uh
the term right it's relatively new i
think i tried to build that
function or that tried to do that like
sure uh to do all those steps and like
take all those things in consideration
um and um but i think it's a really good
idea
and uh like looking back at it now then
like maybe yeah that would have been a
great idea to
to have a person who only had that as
their job
um shooting something like this but but
it it it wasn't
i had never heard of it actually when we
talked so i think it's pretty new
sure no it definitely is of course um
ninja you know can you talk to me about
the
you know the opening scene and because
it kind of sets the tone for the whole
thing and it lets you know like kind of
up front if you can't handle this
just stop watching now did you see that
scene as like a litmus test for viewers
where like if you can't handle this and
the male nudity and everything
you ejaculate or whatever uh you know
yeah sort of or like i think that
scene for me is everything like the main
thing that like what this film is about
or what i wanted to do
uh so like a lot of like um
uh what's the word uh
points or um
interesting word but um yeah like um
[Music]
it was very well like also we did like i
did a pilot
for not not a short film but uh just a
pilot
that never like published like
officially but just
during the financing
uh i did a pilot with that scene
so we had already shot it once and it's
like in a way like the main
scene of the film where the main
um what's the word i
am not finding the word uh like all the
power dynamics are on display in that
yeah like so it's like i'm i'm i'm
saying i'm proving my point
in that scene or like this is what this
is what i want to say
uh here it is uh so it's very well
thought and and i felt like okay but if
i do this in
in this sex scene because there are so
many
or not that many but there are more sex
scenes to come but then i don't have to
like
make the point every time like okay i
did it once
and then we need we're like done with
that and we can continue focusing on the
story
right because then the other sex scenes
have much more
uh they have a um
a purpose for bella's journey but it's
not like
okay look at this now like it's um yeah
what are your expectations in terms of
distribution because this is obviously
very graphic like i'm just curious
you know how where you'd like to see
this film land or
and and you know if you're willing to
make any cuts to make this more
palatable to general audiences yeah i
mean i i wanted to
i i'm really praying to all the gods
that it's gonna be
on theaters like that's the that's what
we've been promised but we don't know
if they are still gonna be there when uh
when this covered thing is
over um but yeah so um
i think i mean it's in in the u.s it's
definitely it's gonna be x-rated
and that's gonna limit uh of course
uh have made but i think usually like if
you look historically like
uh that type of
limitations doesn't
uh like it's not gonna shrink the
audience i think i think
people it's gonna actually like have the
opposite effects that people are gonna
be more
interested uh when it comes to other
countries like asian countries for
example like there are a lot of
countries where it's just like
they just are not going to show it with
that type of
explicit uh images then
yeah i'm open to like make some kind of
censored cut
or like blur blur the penises or
something
if that's the only way of getting the
film out there
then i think yeah i think i would like
in that case
rather blur them because cutaway um
is i think that's not like it's it feels
false uh
it feels like it's shying away from
telling what the story is
so then i rather have them blurred or
something just or like
we were joking about like putting emojis
on like a
um you know cucumber or something energy
covering the um
let me ask you this would you ever
consider selling this movie to a porn
website and having it play
on their website behind some kind of
paywall
uh like payroll i don't know but for
sure like i don't
like if pornhub came in and said we want
to buy this movie and we're going to put
it behind a paywall and so
you know you have to take five bucks or
whatever to watch it yeah i mean
i'm not i don't love pornhub as a
company i think they are
um criminals in many ways but i i'm just
every chance to get the film spread is
is good
then i don't know if i want them to make
money out of it but if to just use
pornhub as a channel
that was just an example of a website
not one i look at
um let me ask both of you how do you
feel about the way hollywood depicts sex
sophia i mean can we start with you
not realistic um
i would say i mean
it that it's such a hard question
because
it's really hard for me to define
like what sex should or should not be
portrayed
in movies because it's a spectrum like
there are people who
like stuff that i find
terrifying and there are people who
don't like
any sexual stuff at all so it's a hard
question but i
feel like it's not that
spectrum is not really portrayed or
sometimes or a lot of times misleading
in the way it's portrayed
because i mean i had a lot of pre uh
prejudice when i
like started with this movie and i was
proven
wrong in a lot of areas and most of it
is things that i've been taught from
movies or
tv shows or like the internet in general
so
i don't know i don't think there's a lot
of representation of
how it's really like or yeah
i mean you're not really allowed to show
explicit sex
in hollywood uh and
that makes it you know you know you see
something under the blanket or the way
like sex scenes are shot is very
uh first of all one-dimensional and then
of course like
hollywood isn't really that much better
than
uh like pornhub when it comes to the
male gaze so it's still
everything is still very one-dimensional
i would say and um i
i mean i'm a sex-positive person in the
sense that i think that sex is a good
thing i don't think it's that sex is
dangerous i don't think it's
sex is dirty i think it's a positive and
beautiful
part of humanity and like connection
between people
and it really plays a very important
part of our lives
uh and i think it's we're really missing
out
on in our culture that we are not
letting
uh that part of the human life
uh have a bigger platform or
be like that we're not able to show it
and and in an
honest way um so that that we are so
afraid of genitals and but it's actually
more
i mean it's still like we you're allowed
to see naked women
uh in film uh so uh
it's more like the male genitals and
especially like erected ones that are
that has that's like whoa like super
forbidden
um thing which
yeah but i think we're gonna i hope and
i think
we're that that's gonna change in the
future
okay uh we got about five minutes left
so i just have a few more questions um
i was curious where the name bella
cherry came from and then also why it
was important you to have your your main
character be an outsider from sweden
you know as opposed to just you know an
average american girl what
um i mean i think the the boring and
simple answer to that
is just because i'm swedish so um
i don't it just felt like the natural
i think for me to be able to tell her
story and be
honest with her to relate to the
character
because that was something that i really
discovered while
when spending that much time in the u.s
that even if we in sweden we are so
influenced influenced by american
culture
so i i thought that we are like almost
the same
but i just realized like the cultural
differences between
like everything and they are huge
so i like it's taken me so long to be
able to really
relate to and understand uh
like american people because
yeah so i felt like my main character
she has to be swedish for me to
be able to tell her story but it also
makes sense that she
i mean sweden when it comes to these
questions like issues we are
very extreme in many ways and we're
considered like
the most equally how do you say
equal country in the world when it comes
to men and women so
it i think it also made it like sense
for her to be swedish actually
how did you both react when you when you
found out that this movie got into
sundance and was also a a cannes pick
yeah i mean i was just thrilled because
uh it's a dream coming true um
i it takes place in the us and uh
my main like the the american audience
is my main target actually i'm i'm more
eager
for the film to liberalists in in the us
and and be spread in the u.s than in
sweden so
and and sometimes it's the absolute like
no other platform
is as good as silence when it comes to
that so i'm super happy
i was super happy both times when ninja
called me i
cried um because like i've
asked ninja has as well like poured our
hearts and souls
into this movie so it means a lot and
i'm
super proud of me but i'm also super
proud of ninja
and i'm super excited that the movie
hopefully will get the recognition that
it deserves
and and uh what what's next for for both
of you what kind of doors are you hoping
that this project
opens for you um for me
i want to make my next feature in the us
okay and sophia do you plan to continue
acting and you you know doing that uh
i hope so i'm keeping all my doors
opened um but yes i hope so
okay well thank you very much for for
joining me on a sunday morning i really
appreciated the movie
truly was terrific congratulations to
you both uh ninja and sophia the team
behind
pleasure at sundance thank you thank you